so david hilbert in 1900 proposed 23
open problems mathematics some of which
are still unsolved most important famous
of which is probably the Riemann
hypothesis you've thought about and
presented about the Hilbert problems of
computer vision so let me ask what to
you today I don't know when the last
year you've presented that 2015 but
versions of eight you're kind of the the
face and the spokesperson for computer
vision see yeah it's your job to state
what the problem the open problems are
for the field so what today are the
Hilbert problems of computer vision do
you think let me pick pick one to which
I regard as clearly clearly unsolved
which is what I would call long-form
with your understanding so so we have a
video clip and we want to understand the
behavior in there in terms of agents
there goes intentionality and make
predictions about what might happen you
know so so that that kind of
understanding which goes away from
atomic visual action so so in the short
range the question is are you sitting
are you standing are you catching a ball
right that we can do now or vien even if
we can't do it fully accurately we if we
can do it at 50 percent maybe next year
we'll do it at 65 and so forth but I
think the long range with your
understanding I don't think we we can do
today well today and that means so long
and it blends into cognition that's the
reason I writes challenging and she has
a track you have to understand entities
if to understand the sgz have to track
them and you have to have some kind of
model of their behavior correct and
there and if that behavior might be
these are these are agents so they are
not just like passive objects but the
agent so therefore we they might they
would exhibit goal-directed behavior
okay so this is this is one area then I
will talk about understanding the world
in 3d now this may seem paradoxical
because in a way we have been able to do
3d understanding even like 30 years ago
right but I don't think we currently
have the richness of 3d understanding in
our computer vision system that we would
like because so let me elaborate on that
a bit so currently we have two kinds of
techniques which are not fully unified
so there are the kinds of techniques
from multi-view geometry that you have
multiple pictures of a scene and you do
a reconstruction using stereoscopic
vision or structure for motion but these
techniques do not they totally fail if
you just have a single view because they
are relying on this this multiple view
geometry okay
then we have some techniques that we
have developed in the computer vision
community which tried to guess 3d from
single views and these techniques are
based on on a supervised learning and
they are based on having a training time
3d models of objects available and this
is completely unnatural supervision
right that's not a CAD models are not
injected into your brains okay so what
would I like what I would like would be
a kind of learning as you move around
the world notion of 3d so so we we have
our succession of visual experiences and
from those we so in as part of that I
might see a chair from different
viewpoints on a table from viewpoint
different viewpoints and so on now as
part that enables me to build some
internal representation and then next
time I just see a single photograph and
it may not even be of that chair it's of
some other chair and I have a guess of
what it's 3d shape is like so you're
almost
the CAD model kind of yeah implicitly I
mean literally I mean the CAD model need
not be in the same form as used by
computer graphics programs hidden in the
representation it's hidden in the
representation the ability to predict
new views and what I would see if I went
to such-and-such position by the way and
a small tangent on that are you
uncomfortable with neural networks that
do achieve visual understanding that do
for example achieve this kind of 3d
understanding and you don't know how
they you don't know the repet you're not
able to interest but you're not able to
visualize or understand or interact with
the representation so the fact that
they're not or may not be explainable
yeah I think that's fine to me that is
so yeah so let me put some caveats on
that so it depends on the setting so
first of all I think the humans are not
explainable so and that's the really
good point
so we one human to another human is not
fully explainable I think there are
settings where explain ability matters
and this might these are these might be
for example questions on medical
diagnosis so I'm in a setting where
maybe the doctor may be a computer
program has made a certain diagnosis and
then depending on the diagnosis perhaps
I should have treatment a or treatment B
right so now is the computer programs
diagnosis based on data which was data
collected of four American males who are
in their 30s and 40s and maybe not so
relevant to me maybe it is relevant you
know etc etc and we I mean in medical
diagnosis we have major issues to do
with the reference class so we may have
acquired statistics from one group of
people and apply
to a different group of people who may
not share all the same characteristics
the data might have there might be error
bars in the prediction so that
prediction should really be taken with a
huge grain of salt and but this has an
impact on what treatments should be
picked right so so there are settings
where I want to know more than just this
is the answer but what I acknowledge is
that so that's why in that sense the
explain ability and interpreter ability
may matter it's about giving error
bounds and a better sense of the quality
of the decision where what I wear I'm
willing to sacrifice interpretability is
that I believe that they can be systems
which can be highly performant but which
are internally black boxes and that
seems to be words headed some of the
best performing systems are essentially
black boxes yeah fundamentally by their
construction you and I are black boxes
to each other yeah so the nice thing
about the black boxes we are is so we
ourselves are black boxes but we're also
the those of us who are charming are
able to convince others like explain the
black what's going on inside the black
box with narratives of stories
so in some sense neural networks don't
have to actually explain what's going on
inside they just have to come up with
stories real or fake that convince you
that they know what's going on and I'm
sure we can do that we can create those
near those stories neural networks can
create those stories yeah
and the transformer will be involved
you